what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to an entrepreneurs in
cars video
um
labeled how long should i wait to be
intimate before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos um i'm
also went on a live with him today so
if you guys are interested i actually
talk to him in person sort of virtually
okay my brothers from another mother so
i'm gonna do a quick video here i got a
comment from a subscriber in one of my
past videos i've been meaning to respond
to
and his question basically has to do
with um you know can you do a video on
i've got my specs today so i'm gonna be
a little squinty on how long it's normal
to wait before you have sex with a woman
he goes i used to be paid about it but
nowadays if nothing happens within a
week i'm gone uh he shares a personal
experience
and then a woman
provides her advice um she says i see
your point but leave your past in the
past three months max under one month
you will get low quality women so if
you're sleeping with her under and if
she sleeps with you in under a month
this woman's suggesting you're going to
get a low quality woman
pro progress measure indicators i'm not
sure what that means but then she goes
second month lots of kissing hugs and
affection
and then it says be a provider a
protector tell her your feelings
and her painties will drop on their own
um
i did a video on why women's dating
advice isn't that useful it's because
well i'll put the card up you can check
it out but
what i want to do now is i want to read
you a little excerpt from
the rational mail i know i've
recommended it to quite a few guys in
the past and many of you have read it
but
one of rolo tomasi's on rules is uh
number three says any woman who makes
you wait for sex or by her action
implies she's making you wait for sex
the sex is never worth the wait that's
been my experience actually i'll share
this i would imagine because if she's
making you wait
like
she probably doesn't have sex with as
many people sorry after this
when the woman makes you wait for sex
you are not their highest priority
sexuality is spontaneous is a
spontaneous chemical reaction between
you and your partner
not a process of negotiation it's sex
first then relationship not the other
way around
a woman who wants to [ __ ] you will fly
across the country crawl under barbed
wire climb through your second story
bedroom window [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of you
and then wait patiently inside your
closet while your wife comes home early
from work
all right we live very different lives
women who wait sorry women who want to
[ __ ] you will find a way to [ __ ] you
the girl that tells you that she wants a
relationship first is this is the very
same girl who [ __ ] the hot guy at the
foam cannon party in cancun only half an
hour after meeting him at spring break
true story
if a girl is that into you she'll [ __ ]
you regardless of any other reason okay
uh having her friends in a room
videotaping at the party blah blah so oh
my gosh
oh my gosh no
no
why on earth would i sleep with someone
that i don't know he goes on basically
just to just to suggest that
um essentially if she's going to make
you wait for sex or play the
um you know the [ __ ] control game
there's a song by prince called [ __ ]
control
i'll try to look it up and put a link to
it it's a really funny song uh came out
i think in my early 20s but um
yeah it's really never worth the wait
and i agree with what he's saying it's a
spontaneous chemical reaction it is not
something to be negotiated so using it
as a tool to barter uh i vehemently
disagree with that now let me show you
share with you a quick story before we
wrap this up one
um in a second
get rid of that music and um
there was this one woman that i had met
who
uh i connected with off a dating app and
we uh we met up when she showed up
you know it's one of those scenarios
where she looked like
you know whatever let's say eight out of
ten and she shows up and she's two
points lower like she's a six out of ten
pictures might have been older you know
from an angle that hid the extra weight
so i like i pretty much knew that i just
wasn't that into her but uh you know she
was smart and worth having a chat with
so we had a drink and she starts telling
me about how she makes guys wait at
least i think it was nine dates before
she'll sleep with them
i already knew that i wasn't interested
and it wasn't going anywhere so what i
did was i
i guess i started to educate her on the
reality of uh dating in today's world
and i let her know look you know
when when you're dating guys um
you know we connect on um you know like
a level of physical attraction so
visually you know we connect on a level
of attraction uh that's intellectual so
you know we dig what's in their brain
and they dig what's on our brain
we also connect on
a very very intimate level a very touchy
level especially for guys i'm going to
say that probably at least
half of the connection uh that most guys
have with women is definitely sexually
or it starts out sexually and i let her
know that i said listen you know you're
actually depriving yourself and him of
any real connection and could be wasting
your time in his time if uh the sex
sucks
[Music]
because he literally told me on his
channel today that he would tell his
daughter not to be a hoe
but you're basically telling girls to be
a hoe like
and she kind of paused for a second she
cocked her head like a dog that was just
you know told off or you know spoken off
to and then
you know a few moments later she says to
me she goes fine let's [ __ ] right now
then
and i started laughing my ass off uh she
wanted me to take her to the bathroom
um what oh god oh god that was the first
time in my life that i had ever declined
to have
sex with a woman so um it's not it's not
something that you want to allow to be a
bartering tool or to be negotiated it
should be natural
i can't say whether it should be you
know a few dates in three days enemy
basically if she's gonna drop her
panties immediately like as soon as you
meet her
date one or date two um i'm i'm just
gonna say flat out she's probably not
the highest quality woman um okay that's
what i was gonna say
oh my gosh because
i don't know that's like so soon i dated
a woman for about three years uh and we
kind of engaged in sexual activity
within about the first well started
first date and kind of like went into
the second date as well
but uh she was also the very same woman
that when we had an argument she'd uh
run off and uh go to a bar with a
girlfriend and bang some guy that was
like 15 years younger than her that
night so
oh dear
yeah you don't get the best quality
women if they
uh get into it with you immediately but
at the same time i don't see any reason
to wait nine dates that's pretty
ridiculous or uh the advice that this
woman gives where she says you know you
should you know wait three months and
her back and her panties will drop
automatically uh if you hug kiss and
tell her your feelings um again you know
take take women's dating advice with a
grain of salt fellas um typically
within about three to four dates is
pretty reasonable if they're playing the
[ __ ] control game after four dates i'd
ditch them anyway that's today's video
i'd love gosh three to four date because
i'm just imagining meeting someone off a
dating app like
how long does a date take like two or
three hours
like how well do you even know that
person
i don't know maybe
maybe i'm different i don't know but let
me know in the comments how long do you
think it's acceptable to wait for sex um
don't forget to like comment subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification battle i'll talk to you
guys next time